yo so when uh when you first heard the
the well first of all were you around
when the dreams and nightmares intro was
recorded yes
we was at the satai hotel i gotta hear
this story because out like this is a
song that will forever
get played every single club you go to
yeah one of the greatest rap songs ever
created
yeah so it was crazy because
we was all on the high from the dream
chasers to mixtape
classic it was incredible you know what
i'm saying it was like we made that
project in l.a at the boom boom room and
like
that was probably like the funnest
project i ever worked on on my life
because that was like we all just coming
up and
we learned we new to l.a we're living in
l.a now
you know and it's just like the studio
we had it was just like great energy you
know what i'm saying
and this before like instagram took off
so like of course of course a lot of the
women that were instagram big models
this day were like you know just around
hanging out with us it was just
great energy made that project
then me goes on tour and they like well
we need an album we like
we still got three or four songs coming
out from this mixtape
so um me gets off tour and we have ross
house and he plays us like the beginning
with the strings and all the piano we
like
what the [ __ ] is this you know this [ __ ]
is crazy so then
he um was like yo but this is what i'm
gonna do right here in this party stop
dude i'm gonna have to be
bullied do this power boom boom so then
like two or three days later we got this
thai hotel and he got the beat finish
and he just went in the booth right and
he like kind of surprised us
and that [ __ ] hold up wait a minute oh
man it was like
[ __ ] was crazy and like we knew right
then and there that that [ __ ] was a
smash
but we ain't think that [ __ ] was gonna
be like one of the biggest songs yeah
it's crazy because when you hear that
record
you're like this is a great intro but to
ever think that that's like a record
that would work in the club
yeah you would never think that yeah
because we would have went with that for
the first single
and also you would never even think to
go for that as you said like
there's no drought is the first single
no hook no nothing
so it was interesting but you know man
listen man everything happens for a
reason so
what was the the first single from now
i'm young and getting it yeah that's
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah who was it who's on
purple bangs kirk
oh wow shout out to kirk
yep cause i was aiming on his project at
warner brothers wow
yeah that's crazy and he had like two
joints that were number one so i'm like
yo drinking my cup yeah kirko's a very
talented kid man
so it was good time shout out kurt
cobains man